[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro tu sais tu toi zir voici le
sommaire ce mercredi 14 octobre le
président de la république a décrété un
couvre-feu francilien de 21 heures 6
heures du matin effectif samedi minuit
nous verrons comment le monde des
loisirs et de la culture a réagi à cette
annonce et qu'on s'adapte et les
journées nationales de l'architecturé
sont maintenus à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette année la
programmation se concentre autour de
l'hyper centre de montigny le bretonneux
et puis enfin l'agenda complet de vos
sorties du week end au programme une
exposition un événement dans piroi et du
cinéma
je vous le disais en titre le président
de la république
emmanuel macron dans une allocution
télévisée hier soir a décrété un
couvre-feu de 21h à 6h du matin effectif
à partir de samedi minuit dans toute
l'île de france
cette annonce tombe comme un couperet
pour le secteur de la culture et des
loisirs
un reportage de patrick jacq de dix
minutes
astrid bergère et michael et lui dont
l'oise un grand public les cinémas font
partie de la liste des commerces qui
doivent baisser le rideau à 21h alors
que leur clientèle vient principalement
le soir une dure réalité pour les
directeurs du ciné cet élan cours au gps
surprise d'apprendre ça comme ça donc on
est en plein de réactions en pleine
réorganisation évidemment dans tous les
cinémas concernés par ce couvre-feu
donc moi je pense qu'effectivement on va
rajouter des séances va on va supprimer
les séances de 20 heures autre solution
envisagée décaler les séances plutôt et
les organiser de manière à ce que les
dernières soit aux alentours de 19
heures à peine le temps de prendre une
boisson à la sortie du cinéma
les restaurants et bars sont aussi
concernés par cette mesure ça va être
compliqué moi ça on verra on verra pas
qu'à partir de de la semaine prochaine
comment sans mal géré et comment seront
les gens s'ils seront
toujours présente et dans le domaine du
sport se couvre feu entraîne une
réorganisation des séances et des
horaires d'entraînement le soir pour
l'ensemble des clubs évinois comme au
rugby club de versailles les
conséquences sont surtout
organisationnel avec l'avancée de tous
les horaires d'entraînement notamment
pour les seniors et les juniors qui
s'entraînait jusqu'à 21h30 au 20h30
évidemment avant c'est désormais à 19
heures pour terminer à 20h15 20h30 grand
maximum et pour que tout le monde soit
rentré chez soi à 21h même si certains
sports ont déjà anticipé la nouvelle
pour les associations et les salles de
spectacles des discussions sont encore
en cours au sein du gouvernement et pour
parler davantage de ce sujet justin
brasier bonsoir bonsoir le monde de la
culture fait partie des secteurs
directement touchés par les annonces du
chef de l'état c'est un nouveau coup de
massue pour les salles de spectacles et
de cinéma qui vont devoir est bien
respecté le couvre-feu de 21h à l'or est
ce qu'ils vont s'adapter ou fermée mais
c'est vrai c'est de là que les mesures
gouvernementales vont une nouvelle fois
impacté le monde culturel qui commençait
tout juste à reprendre alors pour
l'heure les acteurs locaux entendent se
mobiliser pour maintenir une offre est
resté ouvert donc s'adapter tout en
respectant bien sûr le couvre-feu de 21h
à l'or quelle solution faire moins de
séances adapter les horaires des
spectacles
elle est sale n'ont finalement que 48
heures pour agir on est un peu pris de
court un emballage apprend par exemple
pour un concert qui a qui a lieu samedi
c'est vrai que en termes de
communication va être un peu court pour
dire aux gens c'est par à 20h30 c'est à
18h on risque de perdre on risque de
perdre beaucoup de monde en route
je pense qu'on va décaler les sens
fectivement plutôt salaires on va
peut-être organiser les dernières
séances vers 18h30 19h de façon à ce
qu'à 21h les cinémas soit fermé
alors apparemment il pourrait y avoir
une discussion avec la ministre de la
culture roselyne bachelot oui pour
parler notamment des mesures qui
viennent d'être annoncées pour essayer
peut-être de trouver des solutions il y
a notamment une dérogation qui pourrait
être envisagée à savoir en fait que pour
la plupart d'entre eux ils tentent de
s'organiser pour fermer à 22h30 et
laisser le temps au spectateur de
pouvoir rentrer chez eux avant 21h et si
la dérogation est acceptée en fait il
suffirait simplement après 21h de
montrer son billet il est possible je
dirais pas probable que d'ici la fin de
la journée les théâtres puisse avoir une
dérogation pour terminer à 21h c'est à
dire l'idée c'est que les publics puis
s'est justifié avec leurs billets de
leur sortie du théâtre pour rentrer chez
eux un peu plus tard et économiquement
dans le monde culturel quel va être
l'impact alors l'impact est déjà là
depuis la première vague à savoir que
pour les salles de spectacles et de
théâtre ou encore de cinéma les
établissements publics et privés sont
impactés de façon différente c'est à
dire que les théâtres privés par exemple
repose en grande partie sur les recettes
de la billetterie et les théâtres
publics bénéficient de subventions mais
dans tous les cas il y aura un grand un
grand impact est une activité en baisse
à hier midi
on était à plus de 50 % de chute de
chiffre d'affaires ce que nous notre
fils va faire montansier il est
constitué d'une part par la billetterie
et d'autre part par des tournages et des
populations
hélas aujourd'hui j'ai zéro tournage 04
saut alors justin est ce que vous avez
peut-être des chiffres concrets à nous
donner ce soir
alors oui il y a des chiffres concrets
mais qui date du 6 juillet
il concerne l impact de la crise
sanitaire sur les secteurs culturels
mais donc bien avant ces nouvelles
mesures gouvernementales
le ministère de la culture a annoncé
notamment une baisse moyenne et
j'insiste sur moyenne puisque en fait
tous les secteurs ne sont pas impactés
de la même façon mais donc en moyenne on
avait déjà une baisse du chiffre
d'affaires de 25% en 2020 par rapport à
2019 soit près de 22 milliards d'euros
de déficit célia le spectacle vivant
étant le plus impacté merci justin forte
ces informations vous avez dit fermé à
20 à 22 heures 30 ces fermes et bien à
20h30 au rêve pour moi et puis bah on
espère que ça évoluera dans le bon sens
ces jours ci et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
chronique
malgré ce couvre feu la culture et les
loisirs continue en journée et ce
vendredi 16 et samedi 17 octobre les
journées nationales de l'architecturé se
déroule à saint quentin en yvelines
la programmation se fait cette année
exclusivement dans l'hyper centre de
montigny le bretonneux un montage de
rémi lefebvre tout le monde est amené
chaque jour à côtoyer les transports les
infrastructures publiques ou les grands
ensembles urbains
durant deux jours vous aurez l'occasion
de regarder d'un oeil nouveau
tous ces bâtiments en découvrant leur
architecture comme par exemple une
visite de la gare et ses abords samedi
17 octobre à 11 heures
c'est vraiment une occasion unique pour
approfondir la connaissance de ce
territoire
la gare elle est empruntée par des
milliers de personnes tous les jours
pour autant qui connaît l'histoire de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines
terminus du rer c une gare qui est né en
1975 au milieu des champs voilà c'est
une histoire une aventure urbaine
architecturale assez exceptionnel
vendredi 16 octobre vous pourrez visiter
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
qui a été inauguré en 1993 et à 11h30
vous pourrez observer la rue colbert
principales artères du centre commerçant
les publics intéressés peuvent aussi
enchaîné les visites et au fil de visite
on peut avoir un aperçu vraiment très
globale de
différents éléments forts de l'hyper
centre démenti une conférence sur le
quartier saint quentin en présence de
yves droz un urbaniste et architecte
pendant quinze ans du coeur de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines aura lieu
vendredi à 19 heures
il reviendra sur la naissance du
quartier d'architecturé de montigny à la
voulu être comment dire en profond
d'échelle conforme avec l'espace sur
lequel s'installe c'est à dire le long
des grandes avenues
vous avez des grands immeubles le long
des rues vous avez des immeubles plus
petit dans laxe des avenues vous avez
des grands équipements solaires c'est
une mise en scène pour moi la ville est
un théâtre
les rendez vous durant ces deux journées
se feront in situ et sans réservation
dans la limite des places disponibles et
les journées nationales de
l'architecturé sont organisées aussi
dans tout le département comme à
versailles dimanche 18 octobre à 11h 14h
15h et 16h ou une balade vous est
proposé à travers la ville par le
conseil d'architecturé d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement et à mantes-la-jolie l'
architecture est aussi mise à l'honneur
tout au long du week end samedi 17
octobre une visite commentée du pavillon
duhamel sera organisée de 10h30 à 12h
vous pourrez également participer à un
atelier architecture décoratives
dimanche à 10h30 14h et 15h30
[Musique]
et samedi 17 octobre marque aussi le
début des vacances scolaires
des animations et ateliers sont proposés
dans tout le département comme
impression japon une exposition et des
activités sur la culture japonaise qui
débute samedi 17 octobre jusqu'au 17
novembre
au programme ateliers de dessin contes
et jeux vidéo ou de société seront
présentées à la médiathèque du canal
mais aussi du sart à la médiathèque du
phare nous allons recevoir une
exposition et une rencontre donc cette
exposition photographique et des coudes
sonore sur le washi donc le wafi veut
dire papier japonais et donc c'est la
fabrication de papier au japon de façon
traditionnelle et dans un autre registre
le domaine de dampierre en yvelines
ouvre exceptionnellement son cabinet de
curiosités en mouvement à partir de
samedi 17 octobre et pendant toutes les
vacances scolaires
ce cabinet qui est une sorte de musée
d'histoire naturelle appartient en
grande partie au duc de luynes
le directeur général du domaine dedans
de dampierre nous en parle
la salle en fait est une grande salle
qui fait à peu près 400 mètres carrés
qui se divise en deux sous espace à
petit avec l'esprit archéologiques pas
les autos graphique l'archéologie c'est
des vestiges archéologiques avaient été
ramassés par le duc de luynes aux
environs de dampierre et puis la seconde
partie alors là c'est un grand
alignement vitrines avec des minéraux
magnifique
il y à tous les types de pierres
précieuses qui puisse exister comme les
types de minéraux qui puisse exister
nous avons six mille exemplaires de ces
pierres c'est en gros les deux tiers de
des vitrines qui sont exposés et en face
il y a eh bien là collections de
zoologie alors la zoologie vue selon les
méthodes du 19e siècle une collection de
petits oiseaux et le plus gros oiseaux
aussi que faut-il aller voir au cinéma
la parole est donnée comme chaque
semaine aux programmateurs des salles
saint-quentinoise et aujourd'hui c'est
bertrand pinière responsable des
projections à l'espace philippe noiret
aux clayes-sous-bois qui nous parle de
trois films au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
[Musique]
dans les salles de l'espace philippe
noiret cette semaine et pour les
semaines à venir beaucoup de films
français parce que c est le cinéma
français qui en ce moment nourrit les
salles de cinéma les américains ont peur
les américains retardent leur les
sorties de grands films et donc on vous
invite à venir voir des grands films
tout aussi grand film mais des films
français alors le 21 octobre chez nous
on aura la sortie nationale de radio les
cons le prochain film d'albert dupontel
mais en attendant on a aussi un très
très beau documentaire de deux heures
qui suit deux jeunes filles de leurs 13
alors 18 ans un film qui s'appelle
adolescente de sébastien lifshitz qui
est vraiment un très beau portrait de la
france contemporaine
et puis pour toute la famille quelque
chose de beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
large beaucoup plus accessible à tout le
monde
le film polisse réalisé par nicolas
vanier qui nous avaient apporté belle et
sébastien et donne moi des halles par
exemple
qui va sortir donc la semaine prochaine
et que nous avons en avant-première donc
le dimanche 18 octobre à 16 heures ici à
l'espace philippe noiret on vous invite
à venir vous déplacer pour voir tous ces
films parce que c'est votre venue dans
les salles qui fera qu'on pourra
continuer à faire ce travail et à nous
sortir à nous changer les idées de ses
idées morose qui nous hante en ce moment
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce territoire zir
merci de nous avoir suivis bonne soirée
à jeudi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]